من المنتظر ان تشهد باريس اليوم اجتماعا
رباعيا لبحث سبل تحريك ملف صفقه تبادل
الاسرا عن هذا الاجتماع المرتقب معنا من
باريس مراسل الجزيره نور الدين بوزيه نور
الدين ماذا عن هذا
الاجتماع عبد القادر كان الاجتماع في
الحقيقه موعده غير معروف بدقه لكن عندما
وصلت الوفود المعنيه بهذه المفاوضات تبين
ان اجتماع اولا سيعقد في باريس لان كل
المعلومات التي سبقت تاكيد الخبر اليوم
بانها ستكون في باريس كانت تتحدث عن عاصمه
اوروبيه هي التي ستحتضن هذه المفاوضات اذا
بات مؤكدا بان هذه المفاوضات ستجري في
باريس لكن عبد القادر البلد الذي يحتضن
هذه المفاوضات اي فرنسا والاطراف المعنيه
بهذه المفاوضات
تتكتم يعني بشده عن هذا الاجتماع لا نعرف
حتى هذه اللحظه اذا كان يعقد في احد
الفنادق المعروفه هنا في باريس ام في مكان
اخر على كل حال الوفود المعنيه بهذه
المفاوضات وصلت واول الوفود هو وفد الاستخ
رئيس الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه اذكر فقط
بان الرئيس بايدن كان عندما اتصل بامير
دوله قطر وبعده اتصل بالرئيس المصري كان
تحدث عن هذه المفاوضات ووصف البيت الابيض
الامريكي هذه المحادثات بانها محاوله من
اجل تبدي يعني تعبيد الطريق ل اتفاق ما من
اجل وقف المعارك ومن اجل التوصل الى هدنه
مقابل الافراج عن عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين
ويقول الطرف الامريكي بان هذه المفاوضات
هدفها ايضا البحث فيما بعد غزه اللافت بان
هذه المفاوضات لا نعرف كما قلت متى تبدا
متى وكم ستستغرق لكن يبدو ان سقف التوقعات
ليس عاليا وهذا الكلام يعني نستنبط من
تصريحات احد مستشاري البيت الابيض
الامريكي الذي قال امس بانه لا يجب ان
نتوقع اعلانا وشيكا في بعد هذه المحادثات
نورد بوزيان من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك